Ми не думали, взагалі ніхто не думав, що буде така кількість воєнних злочинів узагалі.
А таких звірств просто ніхто навіть уявити у своїх жахіттях не міг.
Коли мене дуже переповнює, мене починає нудити і, вибачте, рвати.
Від цих історій про зґвалтування дівчат, їх також нудить і рве.
Так про свою роботу розповідає психологиня Олександра Квітко.
Вона працює на гарячій лінії уповноваженої з прав людини.
Допомагає тим, кого зґвалтували російські окупанти.
Це люди різного віку й статі. Серед них 11-річний хлопчик і його мама.
Їхню історію Олександра розповідає з дозволу самих постраждалих.
Його ґвалтували на її очах. Її прив'язали до стільця і хотіли, щоб вона дивилася.
Вона звісно розірвала ці мотузки… Кожного разу, коли кажу, починаю плакати.
Вона розірвала мотузки, але її тримали і казали, щоб вона дивилася, як ґвалтують.
Ми з ним спілкувалися малюнками, він надсилав мені, а я йому.
І перші малюнки були майже такі, як перший, але все з меншим нажимом, і менше кіл було.
Потім останній малюнок, який він мені надіслав, то було ім'я "Саша", це не його ім'я.
І він мені надіслав уже зеленим кольором.
І тоді ми вже з мамою плакали разом, тому що вона сказала,
що він промовив першу фразу за весь цей час, сказав: "Я хочу їсти".
І вперше в той день він посміхнувся.
Разом із Олександрою на гарячій лінії працюють ще чотири фахівчині.
Цього надто мало, каже психологиня.
Адже лише за квітень вони отримали 634 звернення про воєнні злочини, з них 103 - про зґвалтування.
Громадська організація "Блакитний птах", яка з 2014 року працювала на Донбасі,
також зафіксувала десятки випадків сексуального насильства.
Його називають різновидом зброї, яку застосовує Росія.
Це не поодинокі випадки, є навіть щонайменше один випадок, коли це застосовано проти немовляти.
Коли сексуальне насильство використовується як тортури, як покарання, як терор, як залякування
і воно адресоване суспільству в цілому, Україні,
то воно може розглядатися як знаряддя війни.
За даними Офісу генпрокурора, юридично вдалося оформити лише один випадок.
Дехто із постраждалих перебуває у ситуації загрози життю на територіях, які контролює Росія.
Ті, кому вдалося врятуватися, зазвичай настільки травмовані, що не готові говорити про це.
Більшість у тому, що сталося, помилково звинувачують себе, кажуть психологи.
Майже ніхто не доходить до фіксації чи документації злочинів, тому що…
Коли у мене поліція питає: можливо, вам надати юридичну допомогу, сказати, що то буде закритий суд чи щось таке.
Я кажу: слухайте, вони ледве говорять, деякі взагалі не говорять. Вони тільки можуть казати "угу", або "м-м".
Проте деякі жінки все ж таки зважилися розповісти про пережите.
Одна з них - мешканка Херсона, яка втекла до Запоріжжя.
Ця жінка живе в селі за 70 км на захід від Києва.
Вона розповідає, не перестаючи плакати, що її зґвалтував російський військовий.
7 березня жінка була з чоловіком удома, коли до них увірвався "кадирівець".
Потім один кадирівець під дулом пістолета відвів мене до сусіднього будинку.
Вона розповіла, що чоловік намагався захистити її, але російський військовий вистрілив йому в живіт.
За два дні чоловік помер від поранення, жінка поховала його на задньому дворі свого будинку.
Не кам'яний вік, 21 століття, хіба можна так, щоб лізли незрозуміло хто, незрозуміло звідки…
Жителі селища показують ще одну квартиру та ще одну могилу.
Розповідають, що тут зґвалтували та вбили жінку, її тіло пізніше виявили російські солдати та поховали у дворі.
На дзеркалі помадою було написано: "Невідома жінка похована за будинком у кутку".
Вони сказали, що вона була зґвалтована, і поколоте горло, вона стікла кров'ю, чи перерізане.
Бо крові було дуже багато.
Це акція біля російського посольства в Естонії.
Так активісти намагалися привернути увагу до численних випадків зґвалтувань в Україні -
попри те, що ця тема залишається табуйованою.
За даними правозахисників, навіть у мирний час лише близько 15% зґвалтованих жінок звертаються по допомогу.
Зґвалтувань насправді тисячі... Коли йдеться про ситуацію вседозволеності, безкарності,
я впевнена, що цих випадків набагато більше.
Наста Базар - одна з авторів проекту Rape Kit.
Через нього постраждалим з України надають набори для збирання та зберігання речових доказів сексуального насильства.
Активістка наполягає, що це необхідно для суду, аби покарати винних.
Збирає докази судмедексперт, це має бути в офіційному місці засвідчено.
Варто це якось міняти. Як я зрозуміла, має початися робота, аби в теперішніх умовах приймали і докази,
які жінки зібрали самостійно, або за допомогою волонтерок, активісток.
Бувають ситуації, коли жінка могла бути зґвалтована в полоні, їй вдалося вибратися, наприклад, через десять днів.
Зрозуміло, що виділень, рідин ми не зберемо, але зібрати докази у вигляді того,
що є під нігтями або волосся, що залишилося на тілі, - це дуже важливо.
В Україні триває збір доказів можливих воєнних злочинів російської армії, зокрема і зґвалтувань.
Працюють слідчі Міжнародного кримінального суду.
У нас є команда - вона зараз не тут через камери - команда судмедекспертів, судових антропологів,
аналітиків, слідчих та юристів, вони працюють, аби ми дійсно могли переконатися,
що відокремлюємо правду від вигадки.
За словами психологині Олександри Квітко, ще більше страшної правди відкриється світові з часом,
коли постраждалі від насильства знайдуть у собі сили говорити.
Поки що, каже Олександра, чимало з її підопічних знаходять втіху в тому,
що резонанс їхніх історій дозволить у майбутньому запобігти таким злочинам.